21 mois après avoir lancé son invasion
de l'Ukraine Vladimir Poutine peut se
targuer de contrôler selon plusieurs
estimation environ 17,5 % du territoire
ukrainien dans le sud et surtout dans
l'est plusieurs villes importantes sont
depuis des mois aux mains de son armée à
l'image de Mariupol mélitopool et
severodonetsk on compte aussi deux
capitales régionales Donetsk et louansk
sans oublier bachmou localité devenue le
symbole de l'affrontement meurtrier
entre les deux camps cette situation sur
le terrain a beaucoup évolué dans les
premiers mois du conflit mais depuis 10
mois elles s'enlisent et avec ce second
hiver de guerre qui approche à grand pas
les positions des uns et des autres
pourrai se
figer la semaine dernière l'Ukraine a
été touchée par une impressionnante
tempête de neige dans ces conditions
l'avancée et le ravitaillement des
troupes russes semblent limité dans ce
contexte volodimir Zelenski s'attend à
ce que la Russie frappe de nouveau ses
infrastructures énergétiques comme
l'hiver dernier un président ukrainien
qui n'a pu que constater l'échec de sa
contreoffensive il y a 6 mois
contreoffensive qui devait permettre à
son armée de couper l'accès de la Russie
à la
Crimée scénario le plus probable
désormais une guerre d'usure qui
pourrait durer encore de longs mois
voire des années KF le sa pour tenir bon
il lui faudra bien plus d'armes et de
munitions la balle est donc en grande
partie dans le camp de ses alliés
occidentaux États-Unis en tête mais
depuis le 7 octobre Washington regarde
bien plus vers le proche orient que vers
l'Est de l'Europe